bonjour à vous curieuses et curieux et
surtout à toi emma qui est arrivé ici
par hasard alors le défi du jour faire
bouger un objet à distance sans le
toucher sans souffler dessus sans aimant
et son moteur non je ne suis pas le
dernier jedi
il s'agit d'une recherche très sérieuse
de l'institut des sciences moléculaires
de bordeaux alors déjà non les
chercheurs ne tente pas de faire bouger
des rochers une idée tu as mais de
petits objets de quelques millimètres de
long des bandelettes de polymères un
genre de plastique un peu spécial
regardez
impressionné attendez franchement on
dirait pas une chenille qui fait du
moonwalk ce n'est pas le pouvoir de la
musique qui donnent vie à ce petit bout
de plastique
la technique utilisée s'appelle
électrochimie bipolaire un terme que
vous pouvez désormais placés en soirée
le principe ressemble à celui de la pile
ou une réaction chimique va créer un
courant électrique
sauf que dans notre cas celle inverse un
courant électrique va produire des
réactions chimiques sur l'objet
revenons à notre polymère danseurs vous
l'aurez compris c'est un polymère qui a
des propriétés un peu particulière
d'une part et conduit l'électricité ce
qui est assez surprenant pour un
plastique et d'autre part il a été
façonné pour que chacune des faces
réagissent différemment au courant
électrique la face du bas est plus
rugueuse que la phase diot elle sera
donc le siège de plus de réactions
chimiques et du coup elle se déformera
davantage en se gonflant et en se
dégonflant elle va tordre l'objet et
enjoint sur la courbure des extrémités
et le courant appliquée on arrive à le
faire danser
[Musique]
voilà c'est la première fois que des
chercheurs réussissent à contrôler le
mouvement d'un polymère sans connexion
physique sans câble quoi alors oui je
vois poindre votre question en effet ce
petit bout de plastique ne se balade pas
comme ça tout seul en fait il baigne
dans un milieu aqueux qui permet de
conduire l'électricité qui appliquée sur
les bords de la cuve et figurez vous que
ce milieu pourrait être comparable au
liquide présent dans le corps humain
vous me voyez venir et oui à partir du
mouvement de ce petit polymère il est
possible d'imaginer de nombreux
dispositifs bio médicaux tels que les
muscles artificiels costaud comme
découverte
m abonnez vous
d